hallo Polen
eine unserer großartigen Verbündeten
Präsident du da Herr von jemenister Herr
Bürgermeister
verehrte Ex Minister und Ministerin
Bürgermeister aus polnischen Städten
vielen Dank dass Sie mich wieder
willkommen heißen hier in Polen es ist
jetzt schon fast ein Jahr her dass ich
hier vor dem König Schloss in Warschau
gesprochen habe Wochen nach dem Putin
sein würde schon Angriff auf die Ukraine
gestartet hatte und der größte Landkreis
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg in Europa
begonnen hatte all das was über 75 Jahre
Grundlage für Wohlergehen und Sicherheit
war wurde gefährdet vor einem Jahr
hatte die Welt gedacht
wurde fallen aber ich komme gerade aus
und ich sage
da steht stolz da und wichtiger noch als
alles andere hier ist nach wie vor frei
die russische Invasion stellte nicht nur
die Ukraine auf die Probe sondern die
ganze Welt Europa
Amerika die NATO alle Demokratien
und wir standen vor einer einfachen aber
tiefgründigen Frage würden wir reagieren
oder wegschauen würden wir stark sein
oder schwach würden wir
geeint da stehen oder würden wir
gespalten sein aber ein Jahr später
kennen wir alle die Antwort wir haben
reagiert wir waren stark und wir waren
geschlossen und die Welt hat nicht
weggeschaut
wir stehen auch vor grundlegenden Fragen
was das Engagement
zu unseren Werten anbelangte stehen wir
ein für die Souveränität der Nationen
stehen wir ein für das Recht der
Menschen frei von Aggression zu leben
den wir ein für die Demokratie ein Jahr
später wissen wir wie die Antwort lauten
ja wir stehen ein für die Souveränität
für das Recht der Menschen frei von
Aggression zu leben und wir haben uns
ausgesprochen für die Demokratie und
gestern habe ich zusammen mit
Präsidentin in Kiefer vor dem Podium
gestanden und bekräftigt dass wir auch
weiterhin Einstehen für diese selben
Dinge komme was da wolle als Präsident
Putin seine Panzer in die Ukraine
beorderte hat er gedacht er würde das
Land überrollen er irrte sich nicht das
ukrainische Volk ist einfach zu mutig
Europa Amerika
die
Staaten des Atlantiks und pazifisches
waren geschlossen die Demokratie war zu
stark und er konnte nicht diesen
leichten Sieg einfahren sondern seine
Panzer wurden zerstört und brannten aus
er dachte er könnte die NATO Finnland
die Serien aber stattdessen hat er die
naturisierung von Finnland und Schweden
bekommen
er dachte die NATO sei zersplittert und
gespalten aber stattdessen war die
nahezu geschlossener denn je
er dachte er könnte die Energie als
Waffe nutzen und
Europa Schwächen aber gemeinsam haben
wir dafür gesorgt dass Europa nicht mehr
länger von russischen
Treibstoffen abhängig sehr hat gedacht
er sei stark und die Führer Demokratien
sein Spar schwach aber dann ist ja auf
den eisernen Willen aller gestoßen die
nicht zulassen worden das gewandt die
Welt beherrschte und
Präsident selinski hat Mut bewiesen und
er wurde gestählt in seinem Widerstands
Willen Putin steht heute vor etwas
Wasser vor einem Jahr nicht für möglich
gehalten hat die Demokratie in der Welt
ist gestärkt worden sie ist nicht
geschwächt worden die Autokraten der
Welt sind aber schwächer geworden nicht
stärker
denn gerade in diesen Stunden der
Unsicherheit muss man wissen wo für man
steht und man muss auch wissen wer an
seiner Seite steht die Menschen in Polen
wissen das sie wissen dass und sie
wissen das besser als jeder andere hier
in Polen denn das ist das was soll in
der Realität bedeutet
gegen
Unterdrückung sich zu wenden und
Warschau wurde ja zerstört unter der
eisernen Faust des Kommunismus hat
dieses Land und diese Stadt Schlange
gelitten und die mutigen
Oppositionellen in Belarus kämpfen heute
für ihre Demokratie das zeigt die
Entschlossenheit der Menschen auch in
Moldau in Freiheit zu leben
und sie wollen ihre Unabhängigkeit
waren auf dem Weg hin zur EU Präsident
sandur der kann nicht versichern wir
stehen an ihrer Seite und der Seite des
moldawischen Volkes bitte
Beifall für die Präsidentin und für
Moldau
Putin hat heute keine Zweifel mehr an
der Stärke unter Koalition aber er hat
Zweifel an unserer ausdauern und er
zweifelt dass wir auch weiterhin die
Ukraine unterstützen und dass die NATO
bleibt aber es steht außer Zweifel
unsere Unterstützung der Ukraine bleibt
unerschütterlich wir werden nie müde
werden und die NATO wird nie zögern
Präsident Putin wird scheitern mit
seiner landname aber die
Folge der Wille des orkanischen Volkes
das Land zu verteidigen wird ob Siegen
wir stehen immer ein für diese Werte und
darum geht es hier es geht um die
Freiheit
das ist die Botschaft die ich gestern
nach Kiew gebracht habe ich habe mich ja
an das Volk der Ukraine gewendet
Präsident selenski hatte ja im Dezember
in den USA gesagt hatte dieser Kampf
wird die Welt bestimmen und wird
bestimmt wie unsere Kinder und
Enkelkinder und deren Kinder und der
Enkelkinder leben werden
es geht ja nicht nur das sagte er um die
Kinder und Enkelkinder in der Ukraine
sondern um alle weltweit und heute
erleben wir das auch hier in Polen wir
leben das in Europa immer wieder
der Appetit der Autokraten den kann man
nicht beschwichtigen dagegen muss man
sich wenden die autograten dieser Welt
verstehen nur ein Wort nein nein nein
nein
ihr bekommt mein Land nicht ihr bekommt
meine Freiheit nicht ihr kriegt meine
Zukunft nicht und ich wiederhole das was
ich letztes Jahr hier gesagt habe ein
Diktator der ein Empire wieder aufbauen
will wird niemals in der Lage sein da
Streben nach Freiheit der Menschen zu
unterdrücken den Willen der freien und
die Ukraine wird niemals ein Opfer
Russlands werden und Russland wird dort
nie Siegen
denn freie Menschen weigern sich in
einer Welt der Dunkelheit und
Hoffnungslosigkeit zu leben das war
wirklich ein außergewöhnliches ja in
jeglicher Hinsicht außerordentliche
Brutalität durch russische Söldner und
Streitkräfte sie haben fürchterliche
Dinge begangen Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit und das schamlos sie
haben Zivilisten bedroht sie haben
Menschen vergewaltigt sie haben
ukrainische Kinder gestohlen
um die Zukunft der Ukraine zu stehen man
Hatsche weißen Häuser bombardiert
Schulen
bildungseinrichten
Einrichtungen niemand kann seinen Blick
abwenden von diesen Scheußlichkeiten die
Russland gegen das ukrainische Volk
begangen hat und begeht es ist wirklich
fürchterlich
außerordentlich war aber auch die
Reaktion des ukrainischen Volkes und der
Welt ein Jahr nachdem die Bomben auf das
Land niedergingen und russische Panzer
ins Lande einräumen ist die UK keine
nach wie vor unabhängig und frei
[Musik]
sein
keine Kämpfer wieder Territorium sich
angeeignet in diesen Gebieten weht
wieder stolz die gelb Blaue Flagge
Präsident selenski steht an der Spitze
einer Regierung die den Willen des
organischen Volkes wiedergibt auch die
Generalversammlung der UNO und die Welt
hat immer wieder die Aggression
Russlands verurteilt
[Musik]
das letzte Mal war die Abstimmung in der
UNO überwältigend im Oktober haben 100
143 Länder die russische Aggression
verurteilt nur vier vier Länder weltweit
standen an der Seite von Russland und
ich wende mich jetzt noch einmal an das
russische Volk die USA und den Nationen
Europas und wollen Russland nicht
kontrollieren sie wollen Russland nicht
zerstören der Westen plant nicht
Russland anzugreifen so wie das Putin
heute gesagt hat und Millionen von
russischen Bürgern wollen nur in Frieden
mit ihren Nachbarn leben und die sind
nicht unser Gegner dieser Krieg war nie
eine Notwendigkeit er ist eine Tragödie
Präsident Putin hat sich für den Krieg
entschieden und jeden Tag den der Krieg
anhält das ist die Entscheidung Putins
er könnte den Krieg beenden wenn
Russland mit
der Invasion in der Ukraine aufhört
würde der kriegt beendet werden wenn die
Ukraine aufhört zu kämpfen dann wäre das
dass das Ende der Ukraine deshalb müssen
wir alle zusammen sicherstellen dass die
Ukraine sich selbst verteidigen kann
die USA hat eine weltweite Koalition von
mehr als 50 Nationen geschmiedet um
kritische Waffen und Gerät den mutigen
Soldaten in der Ukraine zu liefen
luftabwehrartillerie Panzer gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge die Europäische Union und ihre
Mitgliedstaaten haben wirklich
ungeheures geleistet nicht nur Endpunkt
für sicherheitshilfe sondern auch
wirtschaftliche und humanitäre
Unterstützung Aufnahme von Flüchtlingen
und alle hier heute Abend sollten mal
kurz innehalten und das meine ich
wirklich schauen Sie sich um schauen sie
einander an und betrachten Sie was Sie
bisher gemacht haben in Polen wurden
mehr als 1,5 Millionen Flüchtlinge
aufgenommen gott segne sie dafür
den Großzügigkeit Polens die
Bereitschaft die Herzen und Häuser zu
sagen suchen ihresgleichen überall in
meinem Land in großen Städten und in
kleinen Städten
Wehen die ukrainischen Flaggen und im
letzten Jahr haben die Demokraten und
Republikaner im amerikanischen Kongress
gemeinsam für den Frieden plädiert sich
dafür eingesetzt so sind die Amerikaner
und das machen wir Amerikaner die Welt
kommt auch zusammen um die weltweiten
Folgen von Putins Kriege zu begegnen
Putin hat dafür gesorgt dass die Häfen
im Schwarzen Meer geschlossen waren
damit die Ukraine Getreide nicht
exportieren können dadurch wurde eine
weltweite Lebensmittelkrise an geheizt
gerade Afrika ist davon besonders
betroffen die USA und die sieben und
unsere Partner weltweite haben
stattdessen sich einsetzt
die weltweite Nahrungsmittel Versorgung
wieder zu stärken und meine Frau JüL bei
den reist in dieser Woche nach Afrika um
unsere Unterstützung auch dort zu
bekunden wir setzen uns ein für das Volk
der Ukraine für die Zukunft der Ukraine
eine Ukraine die frei souverän und
demokratisch ist
das war der Traum derjenigen die vor
mehr als 30 Jahren die Unabhängigkeit
der Ukraine begründet haben die die
Revolution der wurde gestartet haben die
auf dem Maidan sich eingesetzt haben für
die Demokratie und hunderte haben dort
ihr Leben gelassen trotzdem versucht
Putin weiter hier hin andere zu
korrumpieren
ein Traum der ukrainischen Patrioten die
über Jahre hinweg sich gegen die
russische Aggression im dornbase gewehrt
haben und diejenigen die erleben gegeben
haben für ihre geliebte Heimat Ukraine
ich habe gestern am Kriegerdenkmal ein
ganz niedergelegt und derer gedacht die
ihr Leben gelassen haben an der Seite
von Präsident silency die USA und unsere
Partner stehen an der Seite der Lehrer
der Ersthelfer der Arbeitnehmer der
Kommunen überall in der Ukraine die
versuchen den Strom wiederherzustellen
angesichts der grausamen Bombardierung
durch Russland wir stehen an der Seite
von Millionen von Flüchtlingen die
aufgenommen wurden in Europa in den USA
bei insbesondere hier in Polen ganz
gewöhnliche Menschen in Europa waren
bereits zu helfen und helfen auch
weiterhin die Wirtschaft die kulturellen
Führer und die Fürst Lady von Polen
haben mit Herz und Entschlossenheit
geholfen und haben
gezeigt was das gute ist
wir danken der First Lady und wir
Gedanken der gesamten Bevölkerung ich
werde nicht dran
vergessen dass ich im letzten Jahr die
ersten ukrainischen Flüchtlinge gesehen
habe ich habe ihnen ihre Gesichter
geschaut sie waren verzweifelt sie haben
ihre Kinder eng an sich gedrückt und
wussten nicht ob sie ihre Brüder und
Cousins wiedersehen würden und in dieser
dunkelsten Stunde haben sie den
Flüchtlingen Sicherheit und Unterkunft
geboten sie haben sie umarmt sie haben
sie aufgenommen und in der Zwischenzeit
haben wir zusammen dafür gesorgt dass
Russland den Preis zahlt wir haben die
umfassendsten Sanktionen erlassen die
ist je gab und wir werden in dieser
Woche noch weitere Sanktionen zusammen
mit unseren Partnern verkündet und wir
werden diejenigen zur Rechenschaft
ziehen die für diesen Krieg
verantwortlich sind
und wir werden alle die Kriegsverbrechen
und Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
begonnen haben zu Recht und schafft
ziehen
es gibt so vieles auf dass wir stolz
sein können die Dinge die wir im letzten
Jahr gemeinsam erreicht haben wir müssen
wirklich
offenen Auges in die Dinge schauen
die Freiheit zu verteidigen da geht es
nicht um einen Tag oder ein paar Wochen
es ist immer schwer es dauert lange und
die Ukraine verteidigt sich weiterhin
selbst gegen die russischen Attacken
und sie
es wird auch weiterhin bittere Tage
geben
Tage die
Opfer fordern und Tragödien aber die
Vereinigten Staaten stehen gemeinsam mit
den Partnern hinter der Ukraine während
dieses Land sich selbst verteidigt im
nächsten Jahr werde ich eine Versammlung
der NATO ein Berufen für den Gipfel
wir werden den 50 den 75 jahrestag der
NATO feiern dieser starken Vereinigung
und es gibt keinen Zweifel die USA steht
hinter der NATO und steht als Partner
bei der NATO und jeder jedes Mitglied in
der NATO weiß dass in Russland weiß das
genauso ein Angriff auf einem an einen
Mitglied der NATO ist ein Angriff auf
alle NATO Mitglieder wir werden jeden
Zentimeter des Territoriums der NATO
verteidigen im letzten Jahr hat die USA
sich mehrfach mit den Partnern getroffen
um dieses starke Koalition aufzubauen
gegen die Aggression der Russen
und darum geht es dabei geht es nicht
nur um die Dinge gegen die wir sind
sondern Dinge für die wir sind in
welcher Welt möchten wir leben wir
müssen das strategisch angehen die
Koalition nutzen um den Menschen ein
besseres Leben zu geben mehr Gesundheit
mehr Wohlbefinden wir müssen Frieden und
Sicherheit aufbauen und jeden Menschen
Würde und Freiheit zu Teil werden können
damit allen Freiheit zu Teil werden kann
wir sind an einem Wendepunkt
die Entscheidung die wir in den nächsten
fünf Jahren treffen die werden
entscheidende Bedeutung haben für die
nächsten Jahrzehnte unseres Lebens das
gilt für die Amerikanerinnen und
Amerikaner das gilt für die Menschen in
der ganzen Welt die Entscheidung die
jetzt gefällt werden da geht es
entscheidend um unsere Zukunft Chaos
oder Stabilität aufbauen oder zerstören
Hoffnung oder Angst
Demokratie
Hoffnung oder Diktatur unzerstörung
durch Diktatoren Begrenzung oder
Möglichkeiten
Möglichkeiten eröffnen sich wenn
Menschen in Freiheit leben nicht in
Gefangenschaft Freiheit Freiheit es gibt
kein wunderbares Wort als Freiheit es
gibt kein Terroristen als Frieden
die Amerikaner wissen das und sie alle
wissen das genauso
und all das was wir jetzt tun muss getan
werden damit unsere Kinder und
Kindeskinder auch diese Erfahrung machen
Freiheit
Freiheit ist die Wahrheit aller
Zeitalter
wir werden für sie einstehen stehen sie
für uns ein gehen wir also in die
Zukunft mit Überzeugung mit Hoffnung wir
sind Verbündete Verbündete des Lichtes
nicht der Dunkelheit nicht der
Unterdrückung sondern der Freiheit nicht
der Gefangenschaft sondern Verbündete ja
der Freiheit möge Gott sie alle segnen
schützen möge Gott unsere Truppen
schützen und möge Gott die Ukraine
schützen und segnen und all diejenigen
die den Frieden in der ganzen Welt
verteidigen danke Polen danke danke für
all das was sie tun gott schütze sie
alle
[Musik]
bisschen
herr Präsident Joe Biden in Warschau mit
einer ich würde mal sagen flammenden
Rede jetzt umringt von Kindern Fähnchen
schwenkenden Kindern die die fahren der
Ukraine Schwenken der USA und ich habe
eben das sind auch einige polnische
Filmchen dabei ihr geht in die Knie geht
auf Augenhöhe runter
ein ziemliches Bild an meiner Seite ist
Josef Janning von der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik
das ist schon eine relative heftige
Inszenierung die da stattfindet in
Warschau vor den Königsschloss oder ja
das muss man sagen und das ist auch
bewusst so geplant worden ja auch gerade
für die Polen ist ja ist ja dieser
Moment so etwas wie erkenne die in
Berlin ja ist also ein ganz starkes
Symbol dafür dass die Führungsmacht der
westlichen Welt in einem Land das sich
als Frontstaat begreift präsent ist und
an dieser Stelle die Solidarität und die
Unterstützung und den Wert der Allianz
unterstreicht er hat ja also beiden die
Ansprache mit den Worten eröffnet hallo
Paul hallo großartiger Verbündeter mehr
geht ja auch gar nicht mehr und das wird
natürlich in Polen außerordentlich
wertgeschätzt und außerordentlich
intensiver folgen weil man natürlich mit
Blick etwa auf die westlichen Nachbarn
in Polen immer Zweifel hat wie
verlässlich sie sind und eigentlich nur
auf ein Land wirklich eingesetzt und das
sind die Vereinigten Staaten und das ist
Washington ich habe gerade eben die
Inszenierung angesprochen
dass das so ist das ist der zweite
Besuch von von beiden jetzt seit Beginn
des Krieges der ist ja einen Monat nach
keksausbruch schon in Warschau gewesen
da hatten wir noch eine etwas anderes
Szenerie das strebt jetzt alles auf
diesen diesen diesen diesen Besuchern
aber auch auf den Jahrestag des Krieges
den wir ja am Freitag sehen werden das
ist eine tolle Inszenierung aber er
hofft hatte man sich ja eigentlich noch
mehr viel handfeste aus eigentlich
Waffenlieferungen z.B oder die Zusage
einer ständigen Präsenz der
amerikanischen Truppen der
US-amerikanischen Truppen in Polen davon
viel Kalorien ja das finde ich
überraschend ich habe selbst beim
Zuhören gedacht dass eine eigentlich
Hauptteil kommt erst noch und der würde
genau in den Ankündigungen und
Bekräftigungen bestehen die Sie gerade
angesprochen haben das ist ja das was
eigentlich auch von beiden erwartet wird
dass er nämlich nicht nur im allgemeinen
über die unter Leistung der Ukraine
spricht sondern dass er noch einmal sagt
was als nächstes folgen wird was die
Amerikaner tun werden das hat er nur
sehr sumarisch angesprochen und auch er
hat den Artikel 5 der NATO angesprochen
die Frage der Zukunft der militärischen
Präsenz der NATO an der Ostflanke des
Bündnisses denn es ist ja klar dass mit
einem Russland das so agiert wie wir das
hier sehen wir zurück sind in einer
abschreckungssituation wo es darum geht
über das gesamte Spektrum militärischer
Fähigkeiten einen starken und für einen
möglichen Gegner jederzeit sichtbaren
verteidigungsschirm aufzubauen und das
bedeutet am Ende mehr Soldaten in der
Nähe der Ostgrenze der NATO also das
wäre das was wir erwartet haben was Sie
erwartet haben das ist auch die Polen
wohl erwartet haben vorher hat er das
durch den Besuch in der Ukraine vorher
schon markiert oder dass er schöpfte
sich ja
es ist viel es erschöpfte sich in einer
Zusage von einer weiteren halben
Milliarde Hilfsgütern und weiteren
Waffenlieferungen aber das ist sozusagen
die punktuelle Geschichte und das was
sie jetzt eben angesprochen haben wäre
tatsächlich eine Verschiebung der der
nato-aktivitäten und Präsenz sein Gut
möglicherweise wollte beiden das zu
diesem Punkt nicht zum großen Thema
machen sondern man hebt sich das
vielleicht auch für das Jubiläum des
anstehende 75 Jahre Jubiläum der Datum
das kann durchaus sein aber aus
polnischer Sicht gehören diese Elemente
ja zusammen also Solidarität mit der
Ukraine und Stärkung des NATO Bündnisses
nur möglicherweise haben die
amerikanischen Spin Doktoren gesagt je
mehr wir über die NATO sprechen und was
wir für die NATO tun desto deutlicher
wird dass die Ukraine eben nicht Teil
der NATO ist und auch keine Chance hat
auf absehbare Zeit ein Teil des
Bündnisses zu werden und dass deswegen
für Sie alle diejenigen kraftvollen
Aussagen nicht gelten würde die beiden
dann zum Thema NATO macht und
möglicherweise hat man dann gesagt naja
gut
konzentrieren wir uns jetzt auf das
ukraine-thema und betonen nicht zu sehr
dass es ein signifikanten Unterschied
zwischen Polen und dem polnischen
Territorium und dem direkten Nachbarn
Ukraine und seinem Territorium gibt
lassen Sie uns trotzdem noch ein Wort
über das polnische Territorium das
polnische Engagement das rüstungs- und
das NATO Engagement wechseln das
polnische Engagement in der Aufnahme von
Flüchtlingen in anderthalb Millionen
Menschen dieser kriegsanbruch da sind
wahrscheinlich sind es ja sogar noch
mehr sind in Polen aber wenn wir auf
diese militärische Investition
aufschauen das sind ja wirklich viele
Gelder auch in Rüstung geflossen dort
ist nicht mehr nur
Lagerort von Waffen Polen inzwischen
geworden sondern tatsächlich ein
signifikanter signifikanter Punkt eine
Verschiebung der NATO ganz eindeutig ja
das ist richtig so das entspricht aber
auch der strategischen Lage denn Polen
ist tatsächlich ähm frauenstaat liegt am
östlichen Rand der NATO und es ist ganz
klar dass ich dort militärische
Aktivitäten aber auch das das sozusagen
Bewusstsein für den Sinn
militärischer Präsenz
stärker
zeigt als anderswo das war in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu kalter
Kriegszeiten auch nicht anders hier
wurde jedes Jahr mehr als zwei Prozent
für Verteidigung ausgegeben hier gab es
die größte Dichte an Personal und an
Ausrüstung pro Quadratkilometer mehr als
an die in jedem anderen Land in
Restaurants ungefähr vier Prozent im
Moment ausgeben wenn man den Zahlen
glauben darf die Polen halten sich ja
auch zu Gute dass sie Deutschland dazu
bewegt haben tatsächlich in Sachen
Waffen Panzerlieferungen weiter nach
vorne getrieben zu haben sind sie das
auch so sind die Polen da der
entscheidende Player gewesen oder war es
doch eine Multiplayer Gruppe von also
ich glaube nicht dass sie der
entscheidende sie sind natürlich
wahrscheinlich der beharrlichste und
auch der der sozusagen unbeugsamste
Player der auch
ja
schlecht da steht und riskiert schlecht
dazustehen durch diese Form der der
bissigen Hartnäckigkeit aber Sie können
sich sagen sie haben ganz erheblich dazu
beigetragen dass die Position nicht nur
Deutschland sondern auch andere
westlicher Verbündeter sich verändert
hat und schon bald hat er gesagt dass
die NATO fällt so fest weiterhin also
dass die USA felsenfest weiterhin zur
NATO stehen darauf könnte man sich
verlassen da denkt man natürlich
zurückblicken wenn dieser Präsident im
Weißen Haus ist dann ist das so oder wie
fällt fest ist das trauen sich dann
Blick in die Zukunft zu werfen naja in
Wirklichkeit
gibt es für die Amerikaner ein größeres
Ziel und das ist die Einhegung und
Eindämmung China ist aber dieser Krieg
zwingt sie dazu ähm den Blick auf Europa
zu richten das ist etwas was man in
Peking mit stiller Freude sieht die Amer
können nicht anders als diese
Herausforderung so anzunehmen dass alle
ihre Verbündeten auch keinen Zweifel an
der Glaubwürdigkeit der amerikanischen
sicherheitszusage haben ja und das tun
sie und selbst wenn sie gewissermaßen
eine größere Agenda auf dem Tisch legen
haben sie wollen keinen Zweifel daran
lassen dass sie nicht relativieren dass
die NATO nicht
ausgebootet wird in den Washingtoner
discords Josef Jannik ist auch an dieser
Stelle danke wir wollen gleich noch über
ein anderes Thema reden denn Joe Biden
hat ein Mann gar nicht erwähnt da hatte
auch eine Rede gehalten hat und das ist
Vladimir Putin wladimir Putin hat heute
eine Rede zur Lage der Nation gehalten
die erste seit zwei Jahren im Publikum
Herr saßen Abgeordnete bei der
Parlamentskammern und Handvoll lesen in
Gäste aber es war natürlich per
Fernsehen Übertragung auch das russische
Volk zugeschaltet wir zeigen Ihnen
einige Ausschnitte aus dieser Rede